Arnold people want to know what is your
morning routine what is my morning
routine my morning routine is very
simple I get up every morning at 5:00 in
the morning and then I go down sis of
the kitchens that reading the various
different newspapers and then go on my
iPad do all my emails and stuff like
that facetiming and some go upstairs to
the gym and Brooke at 45 minutes to an
hour do cardiovascular training
and after that hit my breakfast stick
around you just open up a bit bananas
and strawberries and some blueberries in
there and mix it all up it's a coffee if
that go take my shower thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
you think of Arnold's morning routine
it's also a new series I'm testing on
this channel showcasing the morning
routines of successful entrepreneurs so
if you like it you want to see more just
like it
leaving the comments below and I'll join
in the discussion and hopefully continue
the series on thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon